gay dating and gay life is is not always
easy with brilliantly why it's it's I
would think it'd be easier it's very
easy to hook up but if you're if you are
looking for someone who you love or
maybe you find someone who you love it's
just very hard to keep that going it's
very difficult yeah it's it's long-term
relationships in the gay community are a
dime a dozen really and sometimes I just
think like a woman softens a
relationship she makes you know two guys
always want sex it's very hard to keep
it going
[Music]
yeah it's not easy oh you just went
through a bad breakup yeah obviously
another one that was like a year ago but
this one was only months but I heard the
number I already cheated on your problem
is you going with all these young guys
what about going with like a guys 40 so
much crap if I'm attracted to him yes
seriously would you date Andy Cohen oh
my god of course yeah I can get you him
really yeah
Andy Cohen Andy come how do you know
that Andy Cohen is in a relationship
he's not listen I've seen Andy in the
hall he doesn't look twice at me trust
would you would you bottom for Andy yeah
obviously yeah Andy Cohen just tweeted
that he's on his way up to Sirius now he
needs to get a good look at this Chris
when is he gonna be here 15 minutes and
59 tonight knowledge go to your [ __ ]
hands change oh there you are Love Hurts
I got to make a quick love connection
every gay man wants you you know you
know I host love connection right oh
that's right yeah so Chris just went did
some push-ups we told him to go wash out
as a ass haul okay and by the way Andy's
last boyfriend was 28 years old so would
this make that is true right that is
true but I did kind of say to myself
okay I have to start dating up now
listen I'm not putting any pressure on
ya nobody Chris oh look
[Music]
here's a bow movie and Chris I got to
tell you something upfront because I'm a
little worried about it okay um I'm
uncircumcised now you should know that I
know I know that cuz you're Canadian
okay yeah yeah I don't want to make sure
let me get down to it I do you have a
big [ __ ] Chris seven are your 7 inch 7
inch is that good for you
yes Canadians I told you Canadians is it
girthy the girth is average I'll be very
honest ok alright Andy you got girth
everything's great
it's fat oh it's a fat [ __ ] yeah I like
that okay oh oh good I like that too um
now yeah so when's the way what happened
are you guys ready the guy who cheated
tell him the whole story tell indeed a
story quite it was four months I was in
love with him he said he was in love
with me you know we were planning a
whole bunch of stuck together and and he
was not faithful yeah and and Chris
caught him because he did through
through his sting operation I'm a daph
ake Grindr profile and you feeling
anything for Chris physically I don't
know your type no I think Chris is very
attractive he's an attractive guy yes of
course maybe it's worth it you know why
not what the [ __ ]
here's the deal though and and let's be
honest as two gay men okay
you are a self-proclaimed power top okay
and I am a very apprehensive never
bottom before your bottom but now but
let's say let's say you get like a
virgin bride over here okay you guys
wanna make out and see if there's sparks
or something or you should we make out
you want to make a I'm just I know
Howard in the gay community often when a
when two tops meet it's very problematic
and most people just go well if you're a
top and I'm a top we'll never be
together and I think that's a little
nuts right then I feel like if you're a
bride you'll you're gonna wind up you're
gonna it's going to be okay
we how wantedly start with a finger or
you feeling anything for Chris you want
to go out on a day with him
let's I feel bad for Andy right now you
shouldn't feel bad for me you don't have
to we can be straight shooter with Chris
he doesn't care and I give a [ __ ] yeah
maybe we could have a drink sometime
that voice goes it's an awkward but he's
a very cool guy the thing about it is
Ray's super funny
I love he's super cool super cool it
works for the Stern Show he's
responsible for some great comedy on the
show that's right Oh fabulous yeah he's
a virgin bride which makes me hello
fight it so let's jump to let's look I
don't mean to put you both go out with
Andy I want to go out with Andy if it is
something he authentically wants to do
if he doesn't but I won't say a word
it's fine say hey I'll give you the code
blink twice at me if you want out it's
holding his head open hey I feel bad for
Andy now now at now I feel bad for you
no I liked it I came in here willingly I
looked at your Twitter picture I
everything you know this is all
voluntary go sit on the couch next to
Andy you sure yeah then have a
conversation
yeah like we're not here look at his
fist in his hair from the thing maybe
you are I are you uh are you a muscled
twink where are you from in Canada I'm
montreal oh you're from oh really I like
that what would be a good date first
like like so you don't have to be around
each other like maybe just grab a drink
no I like a drink as it loosens up the
conversation and and then you can think
a little clearer all right yeah let's go
for a drink
you sure yeah all right all right are
you just saying that could you feel bad
or something I'm a big boy I speak for
myself I just said let's go have a drink
there we go all right we're gonna have a
drink yeah all right are
listen love is in the air by the way
what do you think it worked out yeah it
would be the single greatest it what
dory oh absolutely I love that yeah you
mind carrying Chris out of here in your
arms yeah listen I just thought hey I
think it's great you met right if the
drinks happen I don't even need to know
about and I'll tell you thank you Andy
and Chris has a nice ring to it for me
Chris Andy I do want to say something to
you as top K yeah and you are top gay
the gay world is a tough place yeah I'm
sorry this guy stomped on your heart he
sounds like a real [ __ ] I am glad
that you found out now yeah and not when
you were further into it he revealed
himself to you you revealed to all of us
that you're a good guy and that you're
looking for something real you will find
it and this guy was not the right guy I
want you to try to remember that and
move on okay you are so [ __ ] hot I
gotta tell you that that is really nice
thank you wanna do something that's sex
I just fell in love with them too for
the drink now what are you gonna do
I think you were gonna cry crisping up a
little bit I need to remember it's
really thank you thank me thanks thanks
Andy look at Andy and tell him what you
think of what he just said welcome it's
um it's it's really tough sometimes yes
it means a lot then did that happen
I when did I find out yeah it's been
about two weeks now problems it's sorry
are you in touch with him nope lock them
on everything good yeah good and tough
because because you don't like the
person for what they did but you still
have the feelings that you had put
yourself out there you were saying the l
word to each other and that's a serious
thing and that takes a while and you
should give yourself the time yeah but
this guy was an [ __ ] it's not for you
and it's good you found out four months
in and not four years in when you were
like buying an apartment or something
yeah
thanks buddy tears make great Lube I'm
sorry I'm are you crying that's good
radio a little bit yeah
I'm telling you and you'll have that guy
kicked out of the gay world no no I
don't want he's he's not a bad person he
just did shitty things I love what you
just said thank you I really truly do I
really know to help my man out take off
your pants come on